around the world people are taking off
their masks as restrictions ease
many people are no longer scared of
covid19 and are enjoying more freedoms
but some doctors warn against not taking
the coronavirus seriously enough the
pandemic is far from over
also on the show why have some countries
apparently gotten through the pandemic
better and faster than others
we head to dubai which advertised itself
as a safe tourist destination while
borders were closing everywhere else
but first let's take a look at nigeria
the african country has escaped
relatively unscathed by covet 19 with a
population of 206 million only 200 000
cases were reported and since february
infection rates have fallen sharply
on the busy streets of lagos you might
think there had never been a pandemic
we are not selling a girl like before
everybody they are not buying
cannot buy anything okay so there's no
need to be wearing face masks because
obviously there's no copy like look
around we're not wearing face masks most
nightmares believe there's no covet and
because of that they don't want to wear
the nose mask again even in
stores
offices now people resist when you
insist they should wear
nigeria only recorded about 200 000
confirmed covert 19 cases and 3 000
covert 19 deaths compared to other
countries these are very low numbers
charles edosomwan is a data analyst
he's been documenting the impact of
covert 19 in nigeria and looking into
the reasons why nigeria seems to have
largely been spared
we have a lot of guard drains in nigeria
and things like that but if you look at
the percentage of the population that
were being affected
infected in nigeria it would be about
0.1 percent of the entire population so
it means in every 100 person there's a
possibility you might not be able to
find one person who's infected and in a
thousand persons there's a probability
you'd find one person who's infected
grover's hospital is fully licensed by
the lagos state government to treat
covet 19 patients it recorded high rates
of covert 19 cases in the past including
hospitalizations
but dr grover anil says that has now
changed
in last
five or six weeks
we have not even seen
one
critically sick
covered patient
who needs a hospital
icu admission
or a treatment inside the hospital
only 19 million nigerians are vaccinated
which is 38 of the population
nigeria doesn't have enough vaccines to
go around many people don't want to be
vaccinated anyway
i don't know i'm normal
i'm okay my body is fine i don't need to
take the vaccine taking a covet vaccine
because when you are taking the vaseline
you know why you are taking vaccine
why are you taking vaccine because kobe
19 is that covenanting
i don't believe kubernetes because
kubernetes does not exist in nigeria
i'm ready to take it but when they
already confused me i became afraid i
couldn't take it anymore
last december millions of vaccines
expired and were incinerated by the
national agency for food and drug
administration and control navdaq
given widespread vaccination fatigue and
a decline in disease incidence should
people in nigeria even care about
getting covet 19 vaccines anymore
so from a scientific point of view
it makes every sense for everybody to
get vaccinated so everybody's on the
same page it's not necessarily true it's
no longer about the individual person
who can say what i'm doing fine
but it's about if you look at the long
picture
the big picture
it's good for everybody to be on the
same page
nigeria recently lifted other
restrictions including the mandatory
face mask requirement but the federal
government is still warning that
nigerians should not let their guard
down up to now no one has really been
able to explain why curved 19 didn't hit
nigeria hard
but life has moved on here
professor bumha studied epidemics like
tuberculosis malaria and ebola
the microbiologist from the university
of yaounde in cameroon also teaches in
the u.s and conducts research for
doctors without borders dw reporter
carsten vert talks to him about the
different effects of covet 19 in western
industrialized countries and in africa
[Music]
so professor ya boom
uh great to have you here
so um
some people say the covert pandemic
seems to be over in africa would you
really agree on that
we can't say that kovid is over in
africa we've been seeing different ways
now we are
having the fourth wave of kobe that
happened around december and generally
in most african countries so we might be
in between to wave the fourth and the
fifth and also most likely you might be
going towards
what having coveted as an endemic
disease in the continent so it's not
over but what is true is that there is
there are very few cases if i take the
example of cameroon where right now
there is only one
patient that is hospitalized because of
coverage in the entire country showing
that there is a really really decrease
of the number of cases and also of the
number of deaths because of common
let's talk about vaccination the highest
vaccination rates in africa around 30
percent approximately a lot of countries
have much lower rates what efforts are
still being made to change this
maybe also to avoid the spread of new
variants
yes it's important to understand the
dynamic of the vaccination and the
vaccination hesitancy from the
perspective of the population
most of the countries that have
have intense vaccination strategy are
also talking about the west also those
that have been the most affected
because of the number of deaths if you
take the example of now i love north
africa south africa they've managed to
push
to vaccinate
importantly the population and remember
that the question that we have currently
the effect is actually to reduce the
severe form of the disease so it's quite
challenging to now convince the
population to go forward when those
vaccines especially now when the gaze
are very rare
which strategy do you think makes sense
in order to be better prepared for
future pandemics in africa
i think the the most important
according to us is first to have a
surveillance an important surveillance
system
and to have a proper surveillance we
need to carry on testing what we do in
many countries though the number of kids
are reducing is to keep
identifying the testing at the airport
because that's where
the usually the virus is coming so if we
manage to catch the virus from the
airport one will be able to isolate and
to take care of those people to the
vaccination the vaccination remain and
really important especially for those
who are at risk and we know that those
who are age 0 young 50s without
comorbidities so if we identify those
two and the third one is the community
engagement the community has to be part
of the response if not then we won't
have the success that we want for the
next funding for the next variant but we
really need to have them as part of a
solution
so we really need to push more on the
traditional medicine on how those people
can also be integrated as part of the
response we go in the place where those
people are integrated in our health
system and i think kovid has shown us
that we should rely more and more on
what we have in the ground and see how
we can complement with the modern needs
professor yapoon thanks for the
interview okay bye-bye
[Music]
the importance of education in gaining
awareness about the pandemic is evident
in ghana
fewer and fewer people are getting
vaccinated there because they don't
think that covert 19 is dangerous and
many consider restrictions unnecessary
especially in rural areas
we met a nurse in the ghanaian capital
accra
works as a nurse in this ward at ghana's
corlebu teaching hospital in the capital
of accra
at the peak of the covet 19 pandemic he
spent most of his time telling people
about the virus encouraging them to get
vaccinated and observing safety
protocols
but blai is now worried that all the
gains made over the past two years could
soon be reversed as people are no longer
observing the safety measures
i mean it's quite worrying to find out
that people have distanced themselves
from taking the action the the energy
and the drive has gone down
significantly it also means that if
should the virus
pop up anytime soon or any other thing
pop up soon it's very likely that
it's maybe difficult to handle all of
our again
today he is visiting a vaccination
center over 360 kilometers from the
capital
the place is virtually empty with many
still yet to show up to get their jabs
play is disappointed at the lack of
enthusiasm
it's quite worrying that it means that
all the gains that have been made might
be
rolled back which would be unfortunate
i need to be safe my family needs to be
safe
my colleagues need to be safe and loved
one needs to be safe
only 5.7 million of the total population
of over 30 million have gotten their
covert 19 jabs
johnson and johnson astrazeneca and
pfizer vaccines are available
but more doses have yet to be secured to
cover the rest of the population
training workshops like this one are to
prepare health care workers for improved
covert 19 educational campaigns in rural
communities
and health authorities want to remind
the populace that covert 19 isn't over
just yet
we haven't gotten there yet
we still need to do
the education we still need to let the
people know we are not out of the woods
we still need to let people know person
is available they need to take it so the
majority of the people will be protected
on the streets paintings like this are
helping to emphasize that
but citizens have mixed reactions on
whether covert 19 is over or not
are there not fears or not there are no
longer active educational programs about
covet on the radio
or even at information centers so i
don't think covert is still there
i think there was an outbreak of covert
because there was a lot of information
on it
but i never saw anyone with symptoms
so there was covert but it's no longer a
big deal
i must
in reality covert is still there so
though the government said we shouldn't
wear max or it's not
mandatory that's how he said it so
people are taking advantage of that
saying covered is gone
as far as the government said um it's
not mandatory but seeing if you want
your hope your own health to be at save
a place you have to do what wear your
mags and follow the protocol
kaby blai hopes his efforts at reminding
people about the presence of covet 19
makes the necessary impact sooner rather
than later in order to save lives
[Music]
are being worn less and less around
europe even indoors people still wearing
masks in spain are doing so voluntarily
but doctors warn that doing without the
most basic protective measures is
premature infection rates in spain are
rising significantly some already
predict the next wave fast approaching
[Music]
diego velazquez's maidens are no longer
the only ones who are allowed to show
themselves without a mask in madrid's
prado museum
the mask requirement in spain is over
even indoors masks are only recommended
for many here this is a new feeling that
they're savouring carefully
i'm free i think
i think i'm i feel
the freedom yeah i feel the freedom of
not wearing the mask but
that's because the space is very
open here it's very large it's very
large space but if it was a little space
it
would be not very secure i think
at the same time we should make the
immune system work a little bit
the spanish ministry of health assumes
that the danger posed by curvat 19 has
decreased significantly also because of
the high vaccination rate of over 90
percent
for carlos chakwasida of the prado
museum it's a good opportunity to relax
indoors too
it was a bit strange that you could be
in the museum cafeteria without a mask
and when you got up to see an object or
two of the rooms you had to put one on
in any case i think that the most
important thing here is general
precaution
and i carry one in my pocket and if
there's a crowd i'll put it on
or if i get into an elevator i'll put it
on
but it's also wonderful to feel the
freedom again to look at people's faces
to see their smiles
the feeling of relief after more than
two years of pandemic prevails but
doctors are concerned about the new mask
freedom julio armas castro works in the
emergency room of a hospital in elche in
southwestern spain the country has
recently been implementing a new corona
strategy infections are only counted in
certain groups
i think removing masks indoors without
taking into account that we're at an
endemic point may not be the best idea
let's remember that only vulnerable
patients who have covered or patients
over 60 are being diagnosed
we're missing the real incidence
since the mask requirement has gone away
the number of infected people in his
hospital is rising again
many younger people are also being
admitted with symptoms
i'm not worried about the incidence rate
of omicron because we already know how
omicron works i'm concerned about what
comes after the omicron variant a more
infectious and aggressive variant may
emerge that causes severe disease and
this could cause higher mortality
because we still have high mortality
from covid
the doctor says he would still go to the
museum if it's not too crowded and only
without a mask when the incidence has
dropped significantly a new ventilation
system was installed in the prado
because of the pandemic to reduce the
risk of infection here too it's clear to
everyone that the situation could change
again quickly
[Music]
in dubai one could be forgiven for
thinking the pandemic ended long ago
as countries around the world closed
their borders the desert emirate boasted
that it's a safe destination for
tourists but this perceived normality
didn't just come by itself strict
restrictions and mask mandates kept
infection rates low it's a pandemic
success story that worked well
[Music]
with the longest slide measuring 450
meters and the steepest of them enabling
speeds of up to 70 kilometers per hour
the aqua venture park in dubai is quite
the tourist attraction
usually it welcomes 6 000 visitors a day
from all over the world
but when the pandemic hit the park's
future was thrown into doubt
zachar trimer who is in charge of its
800 employees was worried
but the united arab emirates which dubai
is a part of quickly came up with a plan
implement tight coronavirus restrictions
to get public life going again and
tourism too it's one of the country's
most important sources of income
people here had to wear masks both
indoors and outdoors you could get a pcr
test on every corner and covert vaccines
became available for everyone in early
2021
so people really didn't talk about it
restrictions were simply imposed you had
to get vaccinated but it was free of
charge
and i think dubai or the uae had a
relatively fast and high vaccination
rate over 90 percent it was then of
course also really good for tourism and
i think it helped bring tourism back to
the region relatively quickly
the so-called dubai model worked the uae
was able to keep infection numbers low
by mid-2021 when many countries had
closed their borders dubai was once
again a sought after destination
it was helped by hotels like the
atlantis meticulously following the
regulations with more than 1 500 rooms
the atlantis is almost a small town the
water park is part of it
jurg unger is in charge of the hotel's
23 restaurants and 500 cooks
for months here staff had to monitor the
guests in the restaurants and make sure
they followed social distancing mask
wearing and disinfection rules
it was an additional burden for the
employees
inside as well as out the requirements
to wear masks outdoors was dropped only
a few weeks ago
i think it's hard
i think it was worth it it was the right
strategy to approach this with strict
rules and also to be very strict with
distancing rules we're almost able to
totally forget about it
nevertheless people here are anything
but flippant about the pandemic
perhaps precisely because dubai fared so
much better than other places
islam kasim is in charge of tourism
strategy for the uae he says people
remain cautious because they recognized
how quickly the covet strategy brought
back a sense of normalcy
so if you're walking in a mall and
you've forgotten your mask by your chin
the the resident or the guest next to
you would look at you say can you please
put the mask up and i think that kind of
brought the uh the the pandemic to more
of uh of of the mainstream of people to
realize that in order for them to be
able to go about their life in a normal
way
they need to respect these regulations
the fact that we were able
to push through and come out the way
that we did on the other side shows you
that we are ready for for such
challenges to come up in the future
the pandemic may hardly be noticeable
for many vacationers at the atlantis
there's still a mask requirement indoors
though
germans jerk unga and zasha trima
sometimes hear about protests against
coronavirus measures back home in the
news
and about people who are reluctant to
get vaccinated
they think things went better here
because of transparent communication
about restrictions mandatory testing and
vaccinations
and because many people's jobs are
connected to tourism
you can understand the people you can
also understand their fears
for us the fears here are different
they're more about if guests don't come
at all
so that's our fear
because that's what we live on
if you talk to people who work in hotels
they often tell you the coronavirus is
taking a break but the pandemic is far
from over and people still have to be on
their guard
[Applause]
dw science correspondent derek williams
keeps us up to date with the latest
research and facts
today he answers the question
instead of developing vaccines couldn't
we instead modify sars cov2 to make a
light version of the virus that doesn't
kill anyone
this is really interesting thought
experiments so let's start with what's
scientifically possible first
can we genetically modify viruses in
highly specific ways to get them to
accomplish
highly specific tasks
yes we can we've been doing it for
decades and in a wide
variety of of applications and the
molecular tools for editing viral
genomes are now both powerful and and
very precise
um next question can we predict
whether changing specific genetic
sequences will bring
specific results for instance
could we alter specific stretches of rna
in sars cov2 and know
that that'll only make the virus more
harmless well
that's shakier ground but okay some
sophisticated modeling techniques can
predict stuff like that so
let's call that a very guarded yes
too
but there are of course
major problems the biggest
is that virus variants out in the real
world also
compete with one another and
how infectious they are plays a central
role in success so
to have a chance to spread widely our
theoretical
modified version of sars kobe 2
would have to be not just harmless but
also
really infectious
you see where this is going right i mean
every time viruses replicate
they can mutate so
big question do you really want to
introduce a highly infectious
supposedly harmless version of the
coronavirus when
you know that it won't necessarily stay
that way
that's a really risky proposition and
how do you think that people would feel
about being
intentionally infected
although in a way that's already what we
do
with with many of our vaccines um what
are called live attenuated virus
vaccines for diseases like
anthrax and rabies have been around for
well over a century
highly simplified
the concept is basically to selectively
breed
human pathogens and other animals there
they become less and less virulent to
humans until you reach a generation
that's
pretty much harmless for us but can
still leave a lasting protective memory
on our immune systems um by then though
the pathogens in live attenuated
vaccines are are so bad at replicating
in your cells
that they don't really make you
infectious to others um infection with a
live attenuated vaccine
therefore has to be intentional um
through vaccination
not unintentionally by a genetically
modified virus that we've altered to be
highly infectious but but hopefully
harmless
that's a really different thing
[Music]
so is the pandemic over or not that's
the question we all want answered tune
in next week as people from all corners
of the globe share how the pandemic has
fundamentally changed their working
world we hope you'll join us goodbye and
stay healthy
you